a mother of four living in Ohio was
deported to Mexico after a traffic stop
revealed she had been in the country
illegally for close to 20 years Beatriz
Morelos Casillas was arrested for
driving without a license near Cleveland
Ohio on July 23rd she was deported to a
volar a doe yesterday it's considered
one of the most dangerous places in
Mexico Tony Tecopa was here with how her
family in America is responding Tony
good morning good morning the State
Department issued a travel warning for
Nuevo Laredo in December 2016 due to
violent crime Beatrice's husband who is
here legally on a work visa drove from
Ohio to be with her and make sure she's
safe her relatives in Ohio meanwhile
called her deportation unfair and they
worry about the uncertain future ahead
for Beatrice and her family she's scared
I believe she's more scared for her
children for her right now christian
enrique gutierrez Morelos and his wife
Sonya are aching over the quick
deportation of their aunt Beatrice
Beatrice was heading home from work when
she was pulled over and arrested within
10 days she was in Mexico what happened
to Beatriz were the direct result of the
new administration and the policies that
have been given to ice
Elizabeth Ford is an immigration
attorney working on Beatrice's behalf
people with no criminal history are
being told they have to leave the
country in a very short amount of time
when they've built an entire life here
with children and houses and families
and jobs
ice prioritizes I arrest based on
criminal threats national security those
who violate immigration laws acting ice
director Thomas Holman has emphasized
the Trump administration's policy of
cracking down on anyone in the United
States illegally last week in an
off-camera briefing Holman took a hard
line on undocumented immigrants with
children born here in the US when
someone chooses to enter this country
legally and they're here illegally and
they choose to have a child that's
you're a citizen they put themselves in
that position not the US government not
the ice officers so again we're forcing
along the number of arrests of
immigrants suspected of being in the US
illegally has risen in the first few
months of the Trump presidency
compared to the same time frame last
year but the number of deportations has
gone down by 12% during that period
holman attributes that in part to a
backlog in the u.s. immigration courts
that issue deportation orders but Ford
believes the administration is targeting
on documented immigrants with prior
deportations because their previous
removal order bars them from even going
before an immigration court judge it's
an easy way to get high numbers of
deportations they can go directly from
my custody to the deportation plane
people should be able to touch their
hearts and be like this is the right
thing to do she's up she's a mother for
four children and right now the family
is focused on getting Beatrice out of
Nuevo Laredo last week a man who was
also deported from her town of
Painesville to Nuevo Laredo was
reportedly kidnapped and held for ransom
he was returned after his girlfriend
paid nearly four thousand dollars to
Mexican crime cartel anything her kids
can do because they have legal status
here to file that helped their mama the
oldest child is 12 the youngest is four
so other than emotional support there's
a limited amount so far they can do the
President President Obama deported large
numbers of illegal immigrants out of the
United States why has the number gone
down the numbers are down because
there's a major backlog arrests are up
but those cases take time to process and
so they're now six hundred thousand
people waiting for a final order or a
decision on their case President Trump
on Friday called for an increase in the
number of judges so he can move through
that backlog more quickly and Obama I
think said the president said he did it
for some reason having to influence
legislation or something like that he's
looking for more money for both border
agents ice agents in the country to
round people up and judges thanks Donnie
Tony thank you